We have yet another very important Supreme
Court decision, the Supreme Court has ruled
that Donald Trump cannot shut down Dacca.
And this is an important decision to understand
both because of what it does say and because
of what it doesn't say, actually.
So as a reminder, DACA is Deferred Action
for Childhood Arrivals.
The idea is that there are people who came
to the United States illegally when they were
under age.
They were not adults and they were brought
by parents.
And DACA is essentially a program which says
we are not going to deport individuals who,
even if they are adults today, as some of
them are, came here when they were children,
not by their choice, not because they said,
I'm going to do something which I know is
against the law, but because they were brought
here by their parents.
And it's a completely logical program.
And Donald Trump promised it's another failed
promise Donald Trump promised when he was
running for president back in 2015 and 2016.
He said he would, quote, immediately terminate
the executive order by former President Barack
Obama, which he called illegal amnesty for
hundreds of thousands of young immigrants.
About 700000 folks, in fact, potentially would
be affected by terminating DACA.
And the Supreme Court has decided it's not
happening.
But the devil is in the details.
And the reason why the Supreme Court decided
this is very important.
It was a five to four decision.
Chief Justice John Roberts, a George W. Bush
appointee, wrote the majority opinion, along
with the four more liberal members of the
Supreme Court.
And they wrote in that decision, quote, We
do not decide whether Dacca or its recision
are sound policies.
We address only whether the agency complied
with the procedural requirement that it provide
a reasoned explanation for its action.
So this is like the most important thing to
know.
The court is not deciding whether or not the
policy is good or bad.
And the court is not deciding whether there
are other cases Trump could make to end Dacca.
All the court is saying is that Trump's argument
was a bad one.
Incredibly, this again comes down to the Trump
administration is sort of incompetent.
The way they are making some of these legal
fights go is setting them up to lose.
Donald Trump's argument was that when Barack
Obama created and maintained the program,
he was operating beyond the legal power he
has as president.
That was the argument that was made.
The Supreme Court looks at the argument that
is made and the Supreme Court decided no.
Barack Obama had the power to do this and
he articulated reasons why he did it.
And we aren't deciding whether we believe
politically they are good or bad reasons or
economically they are good or bad reasons.
Trump's argument was Trump.
Obama overstepped authority and the Supreme
Court determined that that is not the case.
This should be a warning to us that Donald
Trump could try to revoke Dacca again and
formulate the argument differently.
Donald Trump, if he were better and his lawyers
were better at filing documents, essentially
they could have made an argument that the
Supreme Court very well may have upheld and
said, go ahead and end DACA.
So this is another reminder of how urgent
and important it is to remove Donald Trump
in November before he can appoint more people
to the Supreme Court.
And before he can again make what will probably
be a stronger legal argument, what could be
a stronger legal argument for ending DACA.
Now, there are a couple of people writing
to me and I see them posting on Twitter and
elsewhere saying, you idiot leftists who think
you've got to vote for Biden because of the
Supreme Court.
Look at this Supreme Court which made the
decision you guys want on LGBT discrimination
last week.
And now they made the decision that you want
on the issue of DACA this time around.
The argument they are saying that we must
vote Biden over Trump because of the Supreme
Court is a dumb argument, they say, because
the Supreme Court decided the way we would
have decided on these two cases.
And there's a couple of really important things
to point out here.
Number one, the way that this ended up going
Obama's way on DACA rather than Trump's is
because Trump's argument was a dumb argument.
It was just a bad legal argument.
There's a very good.
It was such a dumb argument that even a conservative
Supreme Court had to find this as the outcome.
And remember, Gorsuch and Cavenagh both said,
yeah.
This is a good enough argument to get rid
of DACA.
So if.
Donald Trump was able to put together a better
argument on getting rid of DACA.
It would probably be gone right now.
There's a good chance that it would have been
it would be gone right now.
That's number one.
Number two.
The LGBT decision did go the right way.
But Kavanagh was wrong on that one.
Another Kate Kavanagh voted with the minority
on the LGBT decision.
And so did Gorsuch on on an and Gorsuch on
this one, along with Cavenagh.
So the idea that we don't have to worry about
the Supreme Court because these two decisions
went what we consider to be the right way
is an absolute and total joke.
Only one of Trump's picks made the right decision
on one of these two cases.
Otherwise, you're talking about appointees
from other presidents.
So if you're saying we don't need to worry
about judges in thinking about Biden versus
Trump 2020, you're living in a fantasy world.
You're living on a planet that I certainly
don't don't recognize.
And if anything, these two cases, when you
really look at the details, reinforce the
case for judges in the Supreme Court being
of critical importance in what we do in November.